o portal ainda mais um vídeo é de hoje
vou trazer um fio do mar manejo do mar
com ele né não estar sempre a inventar
coisas agora eu vou fazer o livro da
manhã seguinte eo trio estava sim para
perceber qual é o que eu sei também que
fazer com que eu compreenda trona na
frente da tropa na folha é por 5 10
euros
eu comprei é muito difícil aparecer nos
vídeos uma vez que eu faço muitas áreas
do brinquedo de armas e protetor se
muitas vezes vocês queriam fazer com em
papel
aí eu fiz eu vou deixar só esteve em
campo pesado o papel que vocês não tiram
riso ontem pois são duas da manhã
aí meu amigo do príncipe é o canal
inglês vai carro onde trouxe duas armas
neve para a gente trabalhar qualquer
coisa sobre paz e de salvamento da
intromissão
só que ainda não fizeram nada e transei
a ficar em casa e eu deixou usar mais
neve para mim
aí eu pensei bem estava aqui é muito boa
mesmo que com várias armas ainda todas
até conhecer esta é que eu estava mais é
a volta ao jogo não é nem pronto em
termos de precisão e alcance é melhor
todas podem ser aquelas 1t caras muito
sofisticados completaria essas coisas
todas mas é questão de precisão e
alcance
essas ficaram todas aqui ainda outro
time eu estava aqui que não é nada mais
nada menos do que a junção de três
juntos numa só
são três anos não é só para mim o melhor
conjunto e precisamos não pensa em
bairros da capital
mas como a gente para mais logo redor de
jogo
agora uma coisa que vocês vão ter que
ter a intenção é sair com três câmeras
precisam protocolar com vocês vamos
parar até em mudar nunca vi a primeira
que saiu daqui de baixo onde saiu esta
pois é pois é
você põe normalmente até usou aqmi curso
de pare e produsa em que este estado a
afundar se
então vocês um ponto normalmente e
depois de 20 anos geralmente por um lado
é isso uma vez que sai deste lado em um
tempo para como ele estava a fazer o
contrário pouco depois após um ligeiro
aumento para o lado quando vocês vão ver
isso aqui um período de teste contra
copo plástico como falta de r e vocês
têm razão em onda falar muito rápidos
foi não consigo de graça o vídeo com
fronteiras ao agora é quanto isso que
você quer fazer previamente nem talvez
hoje ou amanhã vou ver como eu vou
paciência tem que fazer uma pequena
alteração vai ficar melhor
aí é isso então vá para lá ao texto
pensava ter este não tenha gostado e se
você não gostar mesmo é deixar sair e
vossa favorito mas atenção só este vídeo
aqui é algo experimental ou seja vocês
gostarem mesmo começar a trazer além do
vídeo virtual que eu trago uma invenção
não saiba trazer um vildomar mulher é
proteger e fazer o que o wfp ontem não
tem nenhuma pra casa de amigos em muitas
áreas e não custava nada em 1950
desculpa para temas da semana estarão
aqui eu quiser um dia bastante um dia
que fazer em conjunto mar e protegida e
plantei sal vai além do habitual vídeo
tem ligações por semana
se vocês gostarem possam saber dele
também ouviu por semana e só eu sei que
vocês não foi inscrito e inscreva-se foi
a primeira vez que tem essa coisa aqui
toda atrapalhada que se fala muito
rápido por ficar sem ar e outras mesmo
local no mesmo pronto e dois outros
filhos vocês podem ver que está pronto
mas nada é isso agora conquistar vocês
não devem fazer e qual o gênero foi ou
seja vocês não devem disparar contra
coisas muito perto de trocar essa pois
acontece isto eu vou fechar os olhos e
usar óculos de proteção
sobrevivi mas quando você não faça isso